[Musica]
proviamo a pensare a qualcosa di
trasgressivo
poi ha qualcosa di trasgressivo
e scandaloso
scandaloso è illegale
ci siete
dieci anni fa per molte persone in
Italia era trasgressivo scandaloso e
illegale che io e la donna che oggi è
mia moglie desiderassimo un figlio
quel figlio però è arrivato è una
meravigliosa figlia e si chiama Barbara
abbiamo subito la prima consulenza
tecnica d'ufficio richiesta a una
famiglia omogenitoriale in Italia e la
perizia che i giudici ordinano
per verificare se ci siano genitori
abusanti o maltrattanti sì avete capito
bene come se ci fosse un nesso tra abusi
e violenze e omosessualità
Ma poi
ancora oggi le famiglie come la nostra
sono considerate
trasgressive scandalose e illegali
nonostante
in questi anni Abbiamo vinto la prima
la seconda Scusatemi sentenza di
stepchild mai scritta nel nostro paese
oggi Barbara ha due genitori dello
stesso sesso anche secondo la legge
eppure siamo perseguitati dallo Stato
italiano
siamo accusati di egoismo
ma mi chiedo non è forse l'egoismo anzi
di più una pulsione narcisistica quella
che spinge tutte le coppie a riprodursi
parola che per l'appunto significa
produrre nuovamente se stessi
ma adesso Voglio chiedervi un'altra cosa
quante persone conoscete che si curano o
si sono curate con la chemioterapia
e che hanno ricevuto un trapianto
d'organo
avete mai sentito parlare di chirurgia
fetale e interventi in utero
e di respiratori automatici
Avete mai visto come funzionano le
protesi dell'arto
la scienza viene continuamente in
soccorso Per supplire ai limiti umani ma
per le famiglie omogenitoriali si parla
di innaturalità
è innaturale concepire un figlio in
laboratorio
Beh il tema c'è
è un tema biotico pensate per la prima
volta dalla sua origine la nostra specie
può riprodurre la vita artificialmente
un tema
sconvolgente sono d'accordo che Chiama
in causa il senso di onnipotenza il
narcisismo appunto il nostro rapporto
con i limiti
Un tema che ci getta in un tale sgomento
Da dover trovare come fossimo nella
Preistoria un capretto da immolare come
gesto apotropaico per scaricare
l'angoscia sociale
un tema
che dobbiamo in qualche modo con cui
dobbiamo in qualche modo
Prendere confidenza
Sapete qual è questo capro espiatorio
le famiglie omogenitoriali il 2% delle
coppie che si riproducono in laboratorio
sono le famiglie omogenitoriali mentre
il 98% delle coppie che chiedono aiuto
alla scienza per diventare genitori sono
eterosessuali solo che nessuno lo sa
perché non si vede
ed ecco giustificata La persecuzione Il
capretto scannato all'altare
ma sono tanti gli scongiuri scaramantici
come ad esempio la propaganda sul
cosiddetto utero in affitto chiamare
così la gestazione per altri è un po'
Come chiamare la donazione di organi
traffico di organi
confondendo una pratica solidale
regolamentata per legge con la sua
deriva in reato
Mi verrebbe da dire invece di continuare
a sacrificare animali siamo nel 2023
troviamo a farla anche noi in Italia una
legge e così semplice
nel libro nata con noi
con mia moglie abbiamo raccontato i
primi dieci anni di vita di Barbara
aprendo le porte della nostra casa e
condividendo con lettori e lettrici
piccole e grandi avventure della nostra
quotidianità
proprio per creare narrazione intorno a
una minoranza sotto rappresentata
e intorno a un tema ancora così tanto
divisivo
scrivendolo mi sono accorta di quanti
stereotipi inconsapevoli abitino in noi
esistono decine di studi scientifici
internazionali con tanto di Peer review
che dicono all'unanimità che l'etero
genitorialità non è garanzia di
benessere per i figli
che orientamento sessuale o sesso
biologico dei genitori non influiscono
su una crescita sana di bambini e
bambine e che le funzioni paterne o
materne possono essere esercitate
indipendentemente da questi due fattori
in pratica un padre può esercitare le
funzioni materne una madre può
esercitare le funzioni paterne o
alternarsi o entrambi esercitarle
entrambe
ma adesso ciò che mi interessa
condividere con voi sono le terminologie
Ok allora pensiamo a un padre
come lo definireste
quale azione lo racconterebbe Se
dovessimo fare una sintesi
non certo cambiare un pannolino
Idem per una madre difficilmente la
rappresenteremmo A capotavola o
autorizzare rette e attività scolastiche
sapete che cosa sorregge il nostro
immaginario
il patriarcato
in una cultura patriarcale si associa al
maschio l'attività regolativa
e alla femmina l'attività di caregiver
portatrice di cura semplicemente perché
in un certo mondo è per tanto tempo gli
uomini facevano le leggi e
amministravano la res publica mentre le
donne si occupavano della prole Ok
allora suggerisco di fare un piccolo
passo avanti e di parlare non più di
funzione paterna materna ma di funzione
di norma e di funzione di cura
liberandoci così da quegli errori
cognitivi che ci fanno vedere ciò che
crediamo e non ciò che stiamo
effettivamente osservando
patriarcato omosessualità famiglia vi
dico dove voglio arrivare
viviamo in un mondo quello ricco di oggi
in cui l'organizzazione sociale si basa
sul modello androcentrico del
patriarcato il maschio bianco giovane
ricco normo abile sano cisgender
eterosessuale
tanto più ci discostiamo da questo
referentmen Da questo uomo di
riferimento tanto più ci sentiamo
difettati noi donne Tanto per cominciare
ma anche le persone lgbt quaplus o con
una disabilità o con un corpo non
conforme o povere o con una malattia
insomma
così via Per non parlare delle altre
specie animali o delle infinite varietà
di vita che abitano questo pianeta in
pratica tutti tutte tutto
per costruire società più felici
giuste
e pacifiche occorre
scardinare paradigmi obsoleti
occorre
costruire nuovi immaginari
nuovi modelli di ruolo capaci di
mostrare l'enorme Potenza dell'unicità
occorre determinare qualunque unicità
come valore indiscutibile e talento
necessario per continuare tutte tutti
insieme ad abitare questo mondo ma non
come suoi predatori Ma come suoi custodi
occorre ribellarsi a quel modello che
protegge i privilegi di pochi a
discapito dei diritti di tutti
occorre traghettarci da una miope
visione
ecologica
a una più ampia visione ecologica
se il mio primo atto di ribellione è
stato quello di affermare il mio
personale diritto d'amare in seguito ho
voluto aiutare altri e altre a fiorire
ognuno secondo la propria natura
Nella speranza che la mia esperienza
potesse diventare una delle pietre con
cui lastricare la strada delle libertà
di essere per altri dopo di me ci sono
tante persone
impegnate oggi nella affermazione di
nuove rappresentazioni nella costruzione
di nuovi modelli
singoli
comunità organizzazioni che usano il
pensiero laterale la creatività le
intelligenze collettive le emozioni
positive per influire su bias stereotipi
pregiudizi nel contrasto
alle discriminazioni così
ho fondato un movimento di comunicazione
convocazione
chiamata raccolta tutti loro e che oggi
è diventato uno dei tanti cuori pulsanti
in Italia dell'Innovazione socio
culturale
ed è un network di Re scrittori e ri
scrittrici dell'immaginario basato su un
manifesto etico e sulla forza propulsiva
del desiderio condiviso di sentirci
protagonisti di un cambio di rotta
una rete di persone visionarie con
l'obiettivo di trasportare questo mondo
nel suo futuro in vista
dell'appuntamento con la sostenibilità
sociale previsto dall'agenzia ONU del
una bella sfida
perché è vero è più difficile diventare
dei buoni antenati piuttosto che bravi
genitori o nonni
si tratta di prendersi cura di persone
che non incontreremo mai grazie
[Applauso]